la democracia en hong kong recibió un
nuevo golpe después de socavar durante
meses la autonomía de la ciudad y las
libertades de las personas
beijing ahora apunta directamente al
organismo legislativo del esclavo para
garantizar que sólo los diputados pro
china ocupen sus asientos
en el caos en la sociedad de hong kong
muestra que existen lagunas y defectos
obvios en el sistema y mecanismo
electoral actual de la asamblea de hong
kong
debemos asegurarnos de que los patriotas
constituyan el organismo principal que
administra hong kong el borrador de esta
propuesta otorga a un comité electoral
renovado nuevos poderes sobre el consejo
legislativo de hong kong conocido como
electo este comité sería capaz de
filtrar y elegir a la mayoría del
parlamento
ya impuso una nueva ley el otoño pasado
que permitió que los legisladores anti
patrióticos fueran destituidos cuatro
miembros de la oposición fueron
despedidos lo que provocó que los
diputados restantes renunciaron en
protesta los nuevos cambios anularían
cualquier intento de los activistas
prodemocracia de incluso presentarse a
elecciones
china generó una ola de condena
internacional el año pasado tras aprobar
una controvertida ley de seguridad para
hong kong diseñada para acabar con la
oposición la unión europea y eeuu
impusieron sanciones por la medida este
viernes la unión europea dio una nueva
advertencia al asegurar que puede tomar
medidas adicionales en respuesta al
último anuncio de beijing ya que socava
las libertades y el pluralismo político
en la ex colonia británica